una apelación rechazada un tribunal de
Moscú negro un recurso legal que
solicitaba la liberación del periodista
estadounidense
evanskovic que se encuentra en prisión
preventiva desde finales de marzo el
equipo legal de gerscovich compareció
ante los medios después de la audiencia
y expuso que a pesar de la negativa del
tribunal el periodista está listo para
probar su inocencia
tiene una actitud combativa está
dispuesto a luchar por un periodismo
independiente está dispuesto a
defenderse en la audiencia de hoy ha
dicho que está dispuesto a demostrar su
inocencia está resistiendo y agradece el
apoyo de todos
Qué es covich es acusado por las
autoridades rusas de espionaje un
señalamiento que tanto él como su
periódico El Wall Street journal y las
autoridades estadounidenses rechazan a
través de su embajada el gobierno
estadounidense se ha mantenido en
constante contacto con el periodista y
el lunes pasado la embajadora Bean Tracy
pudo visitarlo en la cárcel Tracy
también reaccionó al fallo del tribunal
vamos a seguir prestando todo el apoyo
necesario a Evan y a su familia además
Esperamos que las autoridades rusas
sigan proporcionando acceso consular a
Evan los cargos contra Evans son
infundados y pedimos la federación rusa
que lo libere inmediatamente
desde el fin de la Guerra Fría
terscovich es el primer periodista
estadounidense acusado de espionaje por
Moscú el periodista de Wall Street
journal permanecerá tras las rejas hasta
el 29 de mayo esperando el inicio de su
juicio